hey guys it's Monday May 8 and I am
definitely Jessa McDonald and this is
gamespot news with me 100% Jessa
McDonald and knocked down crowd first up
positive detailed how over watches diva
will work in heroes of the storm just
like lucio traces Aria and Gangji before
her eras of a storm diva looks to remain
faithful to her overwatch roots her
three standard abilities are boosters
that increased movement speed for two
seconds and deal damage to anyone she
runs into defense matrix reduces damage
by 75% from a specified direction though
diva can't turn while it's activated and
finally self-destruct deals medium to
massive damage in a large area depending
on the distance from the blast though it
only does half damage to structures on
the heroic ability side you'll have the
choice between bunnyhop that gives diva
an unstoppable state in Mecca that
causes damage while slowing enemies for
four seconds and pilot mode only big
shot which deals damage to enemies in a
line heads-up you'll only get half the
normal xp for destroying divas mech or
taking her down in pilot mode you can
check out the full trailer for hots diva
over on GameSpot or give her a try for
yourself on the heroes of the storm
public test realm
you know who's great at sports what a
catch speaking of my favorite pastime
Sport Chek have announced that Shaq will
appear on the cover of NBA 2k 18 legend
edition the legend Edition is just one
of the special editions available for
the game and will come with a Shaq
poster stickers and in-game currency and
items there's also the legend gold
edition that includes a lenticular print
and more virtual currency but is an all
modern currency virtual who really makes
you think in a press release Shaq stated
that is excited to appear on the cover
of NBA 2k 18 and that he hopes quote my
fans have a blast playing it up big man
style and recreating my most legendary
in-game moments the last time we saw
Shaq on the cover of an entertainment
product was Kazaam which led to the
creation of the urban legend that Sinbad
starred in a similarly titled Genie
movie Shazam my fingers are crossed that
a similar memory questioning outcome
comes from this finally call of duty
black ops 3 zombies chronicles has had
its price detail the DLC which is based
around the Treyarch developed entries in
the zombies franchise will run you 30
bucks on ps4 for that you'll get eight
remastered maps from world at war black
ops and black ops 2 as well as an
exclusive pack-a-punch weapon camo 20
vials of liquid divinium and two all new
whimsical gobble gums if you preorder
you'll also get a dynamic
zombies themed zombies chronicles
launches on may 16 on ps4 with other
platforms sometime in the future but to
make up for the wait you'll be able to
earn double xp and various in-game
rewards on all platforms in zombies from
may 16 so get on board choo-choo
that's everything I have for you today
be sure to subscribe to gang squad to
stay up-to-date with all the biggest
gaming news I've been just McDonald and
I will see you all tomorrow they totally
bought it